women's rights activist and lawyer
Sholem assad bernabéu and the Republican
strategist Peter loom are a very warm
welcome to both of you to see the
program and I suppose Peter we ought to
start with you as a Republican
strategist to try and walk us through a
little bit about how we got here because
on the surface these two were perfect
for each other it was a match made in
heaven the Trump presidency you could
argue started through Twitter but now
they're at loggerheads what's gone wrong
look I think that Twitter actually
fueled the debate between the platform
and the president when the president
said is that when you had riots all
night long when you had the police
department which was attacked by these
protesters when you had the police
department one of the precincts had to
abandon the headquarters because it was
set on fire and there were threats that
they would kill the police officers when
you had gun fire raging in various
cities that seven people were wounded
the president made it clear that look if
need be we have to send in the National
Guard the military he was telling the
the governor that I'm willing to do
anything and everything to assume
control of the situation he made it
clear that we're not going to allow
these thugs to dishonor the death of mr.
Floyd it was unfortunate it was tragic
the video is clear the president wants
to take control of the situation he's
not promoting violence he's calling for
an end to violence
okay well let's bring in Sholem
awestruck by me move at this point do
you think that's fair that twitter was
coming in out of hand they were
editorializing over a tweet because
perhaps their noses were out of joint
over his recent executive order twitter
was absolutely spot on to censor that
tweet now let's let's be very clear what
he said he said when the Lutie starts
the shooting starts think about that
when the looting starts the shooting
will start Donald Trump's tweet was
egregious and unacceptable absolutely
reprehensible knowing fully well he's
giving license to the military to the
National Guard to shoot black people
indiscriminately because that's exactly
what's gonna happen
it strikes the hypocrisy is staggering
in January he tweeted to Iran not to
shoot its protesters saying the u.s. is
looking in April he tweeted to - you
know the protesters in Minnesota say you
should liberate the state now and we all
saw alive everyone globally saw that
these were predominantly white people
who had standing in the face of police
officers quite frankly threatening their
lives if a black person have done when a
black person wanna be shot where was his
I can't stand back and watch this Donald
Trump is being a racist that is what
he's doing right here and nibbling it
Twitter was absolutely right to do this
judge Floyd's death was not just any
inhumane it was murder murder that has
not just happened today but happens a
lot of the time to black people
how many more judge Floyd's I'm Ann
Arbor II Breanna Taylor's must there be
for white people to progress for people
to say that you know we're by acting
this way you're being thugs remember
that the work through a thug is a
negative stereotype used against black
people as well how many more of this
kind of racist attacks must black people
take for that to be changed
okay well let's bring in Peter Lou Marsh
at this point so surely they're saying
Twitter was absolutely right but the
President himself today saying that that
the platform the media platform is
targeting the conservative dialogue on
social media in particular and that he
is being picked on whilst they're
standing by and saying nothing about the
actions of China for example well again
I mean with all due respect to my
counterpart understand one thing that
what's happening right now in the United
States with the riots
it is not peaceful protests and it is
not civil disobedience those are
constitutional rights that we have here
and we should exercise them properly but
when you accuse the President of the
United States of being a racist the
first thing that the President did in
this case he authorized the FBI and the
Department of Justice to ask you let me
finish because I didn't interrupt you
but he authorized both the Department of
Justice and the FBI to embed
to gain the civil rights if they were
violated mr. right mr. Floyd's but on
the other hand you have a governor who
is a Democrat in this state you have the
Attorney General who is a Democrat in
this state
you had the mayor we agree that you have
the man who is a Democrat you have the
City Council who are all Democrats and
they were acting very very slowly and
therefore the President had to react to
take control of the situation when he
called in the National Guard to get
involved it need be he authorized the
governor to use the National Guard to
take control of the situation
protesting and civil disobedience does
not involve looting does not involve
right it does not involve destroying
properties does not involve shooting
each other does not involve killing
other people they have the right to do
so no one is denying the fact that the
video that we have seen all over the
world with the police officer doing what
he did to mr. Floyd may account the
murder but you and I as attorney I know
that murder has certain elements and go
there gonna have to be satisfied and
therefore the president wants to make
sure that the investigation is impartial
regardless of the race of the police
officer of the victim over here and he's
taken control of the situation and using
all means necessary to make sure that
the citizens of the state of Minnesota
in Minneapolis are safe and the
businesses will function without fear
shaking ahead go on I would like to
respond to that I think Martin Luther
King said it best when he said riots are
the lung is the language of the unheard
so I suppose we should be asking you
what is it that you're not listening to
you what is it that you know America
white America is not listening to you
because when you when you take the time
right now to try to categorize what
black people can do it tells me that you
are only not speaking to the heart of
the matter what people have expressed
and are expressing racial violence
against black people these white people
are the violence against black people
then you have the audacity to pass
judgment on black people when they
respond to said racial violence how dare
you you don't get to tell black people
who have had centuries no one year not
two years law and decorative in
the humanization against Peter Lamar
respond well white people ok let's try
to finish her coin and then we'll bring
you in Peter
Donald Trump is politicizing this and
that's what nobody asked him to come
take control when the FBI had already
begun the investigation before he
tweeted about it the bottom line is this
you also saying that it may be murder
everybody sees that it's murder and for
the longest an institutional racism
covers all kind that death and
dehumanization of black people but the
only difference now in the 20th
centuries thank God for mobile phones
it's been filmed so no I absolutely
reject Isis
well let Peter respond to that point
first of all when you define murdered
murder as an attorney you should know
that there are certain elements that you
have to satisfy again so you took a loss
but on the other hand one the president
when the president tweeted and he said
that we get to sleep under control he
didn't separate the blacks and the
whites and the Hispanics and the state
of Minnesota or anywhere else all the
protesters over there are mixed you
don't have a group of blacks or
Hispanics or whites protesting they are
from different ethnic backgrounds and
religious backgrounds and political
persuasions what the president is saying
that if the governor was a Democrat the
Attorney General was a Democrat the City
Council are all Democrats if if the
Democrat state cannot run its affairs
and bring this situation under control
he will do anything necessary to protect
the citizens regardless of their race so
you should be ashamed of yourself with
using those racist statements when you
refer to our ways because all of this is
absolutely sorry to interrupt and I just
want to move the debate on because this
is really important but also an extra
strands to all of this of course is what
will happen next certainly in terms of
this
spat between the President and president
and Twitter because of course President
Trump himself said that I think that
maybe I wouldn't be here if it wasn't
for Twitter he's issued this executive
order we understand from
our sources at least that it could well
be challenged in the courts and may not
be successful but what will the
president do he stands to lose a lot
doesn't he if he tries to shut down
Twitter given it's an election year in
the United States and this to you to
show no Moscow Pramila now I don't
believe Trump can go any lower because
he's already at the bottom of the pits
we nobody was surprised when he decided
within hours of Twitter putting those
facts in did the fact check listing on
his tweets that he was going to do an
executive order everyone expects him to
act like the petulant Petty fragile man
baby that he is so if he had any sense
or people to advise him he would know
that his actions that actually speaking
against what should be proper order what
should be constitutional and what is in
the best interest of the nation Twitter
is absolutely right I mean how many more
racist inflammatory divisive tweets
should we be getting from the President
of the United States before somebody
says this is wrong this has to stop
because all he's doing is engaging in
divisive mnestheus wrong and so bottom
line is this Donald Trump especially in
an election year
he's using this opportunity to try to
place himself right front and center not
focusing on his minted mismanagement of
the corona virus pandemic not focus on
the fact that it's a real human being
judge Floyd that was murdered on the
streets of Minnesota bullets
politicizing this as you can hear from
my counterpart Oprah a Democratic
governor a Democratic mayor what's that
got to do with anything
a human being died and that human being
was just on anybody he was given the
same treatment that people with the
color of my skin I've been given for
centuries that is what is at the heart
of the matter here and nobody's a
dressed man that's what needs to be
addressed